bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
en direct à paris et à washington
kenneth timmerman on commence par vous
quel est l'état d'esprit dans le camp
républicain quelques heures avant donc
les tout premiers résultats
écoutez d'abord nous avons un candidat
dans notre offre qui viennent de faire
cinq rallyes pour sa compagne en 24
heures il a parcouru des états clés pour
cette compagnie là fini à michigan après
minuit ils sont très confiants on voit
que les sondages des derniers jours se
sont rétrécis le président est devant
joe biden dont tous les états qui
comptent pour cette élection à savoir la
floride noyau léo a notamment la
caroline du nord le michigan et même un
pinceau vanille donc les républicains
sont assez confiants mais évidemment
nous ne serons pas les résultats finale
ce soir à cause de toutes les
les démarches des démocrates pour
retarder l'annoncé des résultats
jérôme dindar un optimisme plutôt
surprenant de la part de kenneth
timerman à l'heure actuelle puisque on
le sait tous les sondages donnent une
grande avance à jo baida non il faut se
méfier des sondages bien vide et
évidemment on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler on se souvient que ça avait
joué des tours à une certaine hillary
clinton en 2016 jérôme danard vous vous
seriez aussi optimiste pour le camp
républicain
aujourd'hui c'est normal que l'optimisme
soit du côté des républicains ou des
écoles du côté des démocrates
nous sommes dans la dernière ligne
droite de cette campagne présidentielle
après je voudrais juste attirer
l'attention c'est que le vote populaire
aux états unis malheureusement ne donne
pas la victoire à un candidat
on l'a vu il ya quatre ans avec hillary
clinton c'est elle qui a eu le plus de
bulletins de vote et on n'a pas eu le
nombre nécessaire des grands électeurs
car il faut rappeler que c'est bien un
suffrage indirect aux états unis pour
l'élection du président des états unis
alors oui les américains en 2020 se sont
dépassés en nombre pour le vote par
correspondance pour le vote par
anticipation il reste le vote du 3
novembre d'aujourd'hui attendons de
faire la synthèse de toutes ces voix et
de voir quel est le candidat un qui aura
le nom au nécessaire de bons électeurs
pour être le 46e président des états
unis kenneth timmerman on a compris
votre optimiste optimisme
aujourd'hui
mais on sait voilà qui à ce vote par
correspondance qui a battu tous les
records près de 100 millions
d'américains qui ont déjà voté une
grande partie d'entre par courrier on
sait tout le mal que pense donald trump
de ce vote par courrier de notre homme
qui a déjà prévu prévenu qu'ils
contesteraient ces résultats le cas
échéant
effectivement il a raison pour ceux-là
ont peint ces bannis par exemple le
gouverneur gouverneur a décrété qu on
aura plus de signatures sur le vote par
correspondance c'est à dire qu'on ne
pourrait plus vérifier l'identité de
l'électeur par sa signature
uniquement par le nom et par son adresse
or le problème que nous avons aux états
unis chaque et un garde de très grand
nombre d'électeurs sur les listes
électorales qui sont ou bien mort ou
bien qu'ils ont déménagé et guiglo qui
vivent dans d'autres états et bottes
dans d'autres états et cela ouvre la
voie à une grande fraude électorale
c'est ça que redoute la président le
président sur le système très complexe
on connaît tous et swing states vous
aujourd'hui chez les républicains quel
est l'état si j'ose dire qui vous
inquiète le plus ce qui est le plus dans
votre ligne de mire aujourd'hui la
pennsylvanie sans aucun doute c'est la
peinture animé d'abord bravo pour cette
explication mon acquis et est excellent
pour les gens qui connaissent pas notre
système aux états unis c'était très bien
fait un seul détail que j'y ajouterai
c'est que si dans l'autre on perd est
élu il ne sera pas la 46e président il
sera en toujours 2 45e président mais
bon la passive à nice et d'état qui nous
inquiètent plus haut tant que
républicain les derniers sondages
mais le président on avance par un et
demi pour cent voire 2%
mais même à l'intérieur ou accompagne on
dit qui aura besoin de 4 % pour déjouer
la fraude électorale
comme anticipe en pennsylvanie est pour
les raisons qui expliquaient tout à
l'heure il n'y a plus de ces natures sur
les votes par correspondance et cela
pourrait permettre une fraude électorale
assez important j'ai parlé avec des gens
de la campagne trompe hier ont ainsi
validé avocats qui sont déjà en place
pour contester ddd des votes par
correspondance qui ne serait pas fidèle
à la signature sur les listes
électorales dans celle à qui jouent tous
byden doit gagner la pince wernli
s'il veut devenir président lathrop le
perdre mais il doit gagner la flore y
voilà un peu le jeu électoral ici jérôme
dader vous partager cette analyse de
kébémer man c'est bel et bien la
pennsylvanie qui va falloir scruté à la
loupe
aujourd'hui on cette journée d'élection
rappelle effectivement que la
pennsylvanie avait été un état
absolument clé lors des dernières
élections ça avait quasiment fait gagner
donald trump s'est clairement jouerait
un autre regard un regard un peu plus
historique parce que la bnci bannissez
philadelphie c'est là où a été signée la
déclaration de l'indépendance le 4
juillet 1776 c'est là aussi qu'a été
signée par les pères fondateurs de la
constitution américaine et j'entends
aujourd'hui un autre invité parlé de
fraudes électorales dans cet état
américain qui certainement l'état le
plus historique par rapport à l'histoire
des états unis et à son système
électoral donc je suis un petit peu
surpris de découvrir que on sait
qu'aujourd'hui il ya de la fraude
un tour le vote 1 du président des états
unis
kenney timmerman quand même ça vaut le
coup d entendre votre réponse sur ce
point jérôme bonnard qui se trouve
surpris qu'on puisse évoquer de la
fraude en pennsylvanie sachant que
beaucoup de monde ça choque les
américains ça me choque
ouah mais ceci dit j'ai fait beaucoup de
recherches ces dernières années je suis
ancien candidat
et pour le progrès je t'aime candidat
républicain en 2012 et je n'ai vu moi
même de mes propos du lieu la fraude
électorale
c'est dommage de le dire mais cela
existe cela existe
quand on a une quantité assez important
et cela a même fait déjouer certaines
élections
quand nous avons des listes électorales
qui ne sont pas propres
c'est de dire qu'ils sont qui inclut des
gens qui sont morts et qui ont qui se
sont déplacés qui ont déménagé qui
vivent dans d'autres états c'est une
invitation la fraude nous avons nous
avons vu ces derniers mois des
confrontations de 2 op de démocrates
d'aider des gens qui travaillent pour le
parti démocrate qui expliquait comment
il commettait la fraude électorale
pendant des années malheureusement c'est
ça qu'on craint j'espère ce serait pas
important mais c'est quand même quelque
chose à voir
et il ne candidats trompe le candidat
trompe à des impôts quant aux places
pour déjouer cette fraude avant qu'ils
ne se passe jérôme inde est là on vient
d'entendre ce sujet l'importance de ce
vote noir on en a beaucoup parlé pendant
cette campagne notamment joe biden avec
le soutien très appuyé de sa future
peut-être vice-présidente en tout cas
c'est ce qu'ils aimeraient kamala harris
mais aussi l'ancien président barack
obama on est vraiment allé chercher ce
vote des minorités ce vote noir
également latino pour remporter on
l'espère la victoire oui il est vrai que
joe biden a surpris tout le monde en
choisissant une colistière camara
oui saint qui y est une femme jeune le
représentant la population noire afro
américaine qui a un charisme et qui au
passage par le français donc il faut
regarder ça avec beaucoup d'attention si
le ticket by john harris était lui en
tout cas pour les relations avec la
france
alors pour revenir à la population
afro-américaine
il est vrai qu'aujourd'hui c'est les
deux candidats cherchent à avoir les
voix de ses électeurs là en tout cas on
voit une avance en tout cas pour baden
qui a choisi une colistière représentant
la population afro-américaine 1 malgré
tout on sait qu'il ya une partie 1 de la
population afro-américaine qui se trouve
derrière donald trump
alors si à des banques des états ça
dépend aussi des jours puisque en
fonction de la campagne est de ceux qui
paient une ti par l'un ou l'autre des
candidats
eh bien ça aura certainement une
incidence dans l'urne
mais de quelle proportion est bien là
attendons de voir les résultats kenneth
timmerman ce vote noir à ce que vous
êtes justement pessimiste pour votre
poulain donald trump il a déçu de ce
point de vue là pas du tout en 2016
trempe a gagné environ 8 pour cent de la
vote noir aux états unis ce qui est un
moyen pour les réunions historiquement
les démocrates ont besoin de gagner 90 %
de sept votes pour pouvoir atteindre la
présidence or les derniers sondages
montrent que dans l'autre en plantes
dans l'état de floride par exemple est à
27 % de la population noire dans l'état
de perceva ni dans les états de
pennsylvanie et me chicaner il est au
dessus de 20 4%
et si cela s'avère
avec les résultats réels qu'on va voir à
partir de ce soir ce sera un
raz-de-marée pendant longtemps parce
qu'il aurait en fait démoli le mur du
bastion démocrate de cette population
noire qui commencent à s'éveiller et se
rend de se rencontrer que deux qui n'est
pas forcément ils n'avaient pas
forcément les mêmes intérêts que le
parti démocrate qui voudrait qu'il soit
socialiste qui dépendent du gouvernement
est en fait de viande et devient des
enfants du gouvernement les la
population noire devient de plus en plus
commerçants - petites et moyennes
entreprises chefs de petites et moyennes
entreprises et il veut le faire partie
de la tissu économique du pays et le
parti démocrate ne lui en feront pas cet
avenir c'est dans notre homme qui leur
offre la liberté
jérôme danard on entendait parler voilà
tu sais ces barricades on l'a constaté
ici même à washington n'y a pas une
boutique qui n'est pas barricadé idem à
new york est ce que voulait
craignez-vous ces violences aux états
unis cette nuit écoutez je pense que les
etats unis c'est un pays qui a des armes
des milices d'extrême-droite et
d'extrême-gauche qui connaît des
tensions raciales des bavures policières
bref le cocktail explosif qui n'est à
leur portée est donc aujourd'hui
effectivement on peut le craindre
en tout cas je ne souhaite pas ce chaos
je veux vraiment que les états unis
souhaitent un pays apaisé et rassembler
ils doivent montrer l'exemple
c'est quand même la première démocratie
au monde la plus jeune république qui
datent de 1787
donc vous comprenez bien que s'il ya le
chaos
cette amérique divisé qui s'exprime dans
les rues bien ça va ébranler le pouvoir
et le prestige dont jouissent les etats
unis savent avoir aussi un impact sur
son rôle de
audel et de leader dans le monde on sait
pertinemment que les décisions prises
aux états unis quel que soit le nom du
prochain président des états unis aura
des répercussions sur les pays du monde
et a fortiori sur la france donc oui un
océan quelque chose que je suis avec
beaucoup d'attention et en tout cas je
souhaite une amérique apaisé quels que
soient les résultats
kennedy maman évidemment on en parle
beaucoup de ces craintes de violences on
a tous vu ses reportages avec ces
américains qui s'arme massivement je le
répète ces villes qui se barricadent on
a souvent accusé noël trump art
notamment les médias ici aux etats unis
donald trump de mettre de l'huile sur le
feu il l'a redit samedi va y avoir de la
pagaille dans notre pays
vous estimez vous aussi que donald trump
a mis de l'huile sur le feu et n'apaise
pas les choses écoutez nous vivons une
situation action renner aux états unis
samara perd le plus qu'autre chose 1968
lorsqu'on a eu des émeutes à travers le
pays des émeutes qui ont été menées il
faut leur portée par l'extrême-gauche
par même des communistes aux états unis
c'est la même chose qui se passe
actuellement nous avons un média écouté
pendant 35 ans moi je me présentais en
tant que reporter j'étais grand reporter
j'étais correspondant de guerre j'en
étais fier de l'être là depuis des
années je ne suis plus fier d'être
rapporteur aux etats-unis le métier de
journaliste n'existe plus est ce que ce
qui s'appelle journalistes aux états
unis maintenant sont devenus les
directeurs de communication pour le
parti démocrate
pendant ces trois dernières semaines on
a eu un scandale absolument actions
ordinaires éclaté avec le
le portable un ordinateur portable
le fils de john dryden avec toutes ses
emails qui montre est tellement il était
corrompu y voyager avec son père
lorsqu'il était lorsque bradley davies
président en ukraine en chine et un à
travers le monde pour ramasser les fonds
pour lui personnellement kid et stimuler
encore à son père c'est de dire il
vendait à à des gens à l'étranger des
chefs d'entreprises et d'autres l'accès
au vice président des états unis nous
avons jamais vu ça de l'histoire de mon
vivant et les médias américains n'ont
pas voulu rapporter cette histoire ils
ont fait semblant que ce qui n'existait
pas c'était uniquement le président
trempe qui ont parlé si ça si c'est ça
de mettre l'huile sur le feu oui le
président a mis huit surfeurs parce
qu'il a parlé de la vérité que la presse
que les médias n'ont parlé pas
merci kenneth timerman